A MASSIVE STORM HAS BEEN
BRINGING WITH IT HURRICANE-FORCE
WINDS AND RAIN AND IT HAS TURNED
DEADLY IN CALIFORNIA.
PARTS OF THE STATE ARE SEEING
FLASH FLOODED AND LANDSLIDES IN
LESS THAN A WEEK.
NEARLY 180,000 PEOPLE ARE
WITHOUT POWER AND PEOPLE ALONG
THE COAST ARE UNDER EVACUATION
ORDERS.
STEPHANIE, WHAT HAVE YOU BEEN
SEEING THERE?
>> Reporter: WELL, JUST HOW
STRONG THE HURRICANE-FORCE WINDS
HAVE BEEN, TAKE A LOOK BEHIND ME
AT THIS VALERO GAS STATION HERE
IN DALY CITY, IT IS THE OTHER
DIRECTION AND THE WIND WAS
COMING RIGHT OFF OF THERE AND
JUST KNOCKED THIS GAS STATION
TOP OVER.
YOU COULD SEE SOME OF THE PUMPS
ARE DAMAGED HERE AND YOU JUST
GOT SOME OF THE PAPER HANGING
OUT.
WE CHECKED IN TO SEE HOW BAD THE
WINDS GOT HERE AND IT WAS OVER
60 MILES PER HOUR.
WE SAW GUSTS AND THEN ALSO LIKE
OVER 50 MILES PER HOUR FOR ABOUT
10 HOURS OVERNIGHT, SO REALLY
STIFF WINDS AND THIS IS BEEN A
LOT OF THE PROBLEM HERE.
IS THE WINDS, IS THE AMOUNT OF
RAIN AND IN SUCH A SHORT TIME
THAT WE SAW FLOODING AND
MUDSLIDES AND ROCK SLIDES AS
WELL.
THERE IS ALSO POWER OUTAGES.
WE KNOW OF TREES FALLING AND
ALSO CAUSING DAMAGE.
A FAMILY WHO WAS IN A MOVING CAR
IN THE MIDDLE OF SAN FRANCISCO
WHEN A TREE FELL ON THEM.
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET OUT
SAFELY.
HOWEVER THERE WAS A TODDLER
KILLED WHEN A RED WOOD TREE FELL
ON TOP OF THE FAMILY HOME AND
THE TODDLER DID LOSE THEIR LIFE.
THIS SHOWS YOU HOW DEADLY THIS
IS AND THIS IS ANOTHER BAND OF
THE STORM IS MAKING ITS WAY IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REALLY
FEELING THE EFFECTS OF THIS
STORM AND IN THE SIERRA WE'VE
SEEN HEAT OF SNOW FROM PREVIOUS
STORMS AND ANOTHER ONE TO THREE
FEET OF SNOW.
AND THE ONE QUESTION WE KEEP
GETTING ASKED, DOES THIS MEAN
THE DROUGHT IS OVER IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE EXCEPTIONAL DROUGHT LEVELS
HAVE BEEN ALLEVIATE ADD CROSS
STATE.
HOWEVER WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
DROUGHT AND OVER 97% OF THE
STATE.
SO WHILE THIS IS A LOT OF RAIN
AND IT IS A GOOD THING.
WE'RE NOT OUT OF THE DROUGHT
YET, KATE.
>> IT IS DEFINITELY A
DOUBLE-EDGED SWORD ON THIS ONE.
THANK YOU.
>>> LET ME BRING IN
METEOROLOGIST CHAD MYERS FOR
WHAT IS COMING AND WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN UP AGAINST.
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING, CHAD?
>> STORM NEW ONE IS TODAY, THE
BREAK THAT IS TONIGHT AND INTO
TOMORROW AND THEN FRIDAY NIGHT,
THE NEXT STORM RIGHT ON ITS
HEELS.
ONE AFTER ANOTHER LIKE PLANES
LINED N
LINED UP IN THE LA GUARDIA.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING CALTRANS
VIDEOS FROM THE CAMERAS IN THE
SIERRA AND THEY'RE SPECTACULAR.
TRUCKS ARE PULLED OVER PUTTING
CHAINS ON AND THE RAIN, A SLOW
COMMUTE THERE THIS MORNING FOR
SURE.
HEAVY DOWNPOURS THREATENING
FLASH FLOODING AND AGAIN THE
NEXT STORM SYSTEM WILL MAKE
SIGNIFICANT SNOW.
THAT IS WHY WE'RE STILL SEEING
THE SIGNIFICANT STORM WARNINGS
FOR WINTER STORMS AND THEN WIND
ADVISORIES AND WIND WARNINGS FOR
THE NEXT STORM.
I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT 50 MILES
PER HOUR IN DALY CITY, I'M NOT
SURE HOW ANY TREE IS STANDING
WITH WIND GUSTS TO 138.
I KNOW THAT IS WAY UP ON TOP OF
THE MOUNTAIN.
BUT 138.
REALLY.
YOU THINK THAT WOULD EVEN BE
POSSIBLE.
THERE IS THE SNOW.
ONE STORM ENDING TODAY AND
ANOTHER STORM STARTING TOMORROW
NIGHT.
KATE.
>> CHAD, KEEP TRACKING IT FOR
US.
I AREALLY APPRECIATE IT.
>>> JOINING ME NOW IS TYLER
WILLIAMSON, MAYOR OF MONTEREY,
ONE OF THE COASTAL CITIES
DEALING WITH THIS ROUGH WEATHER.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
WHAT WAS LAST NIGHT LIKE AND
WHAT ARE YOU SEEING THIS
MORNING?
>> WELL THERE IS A LOT OF WIND
AND OF COURSE THERE IS RAIN.
AND THE PROBLEM IS THAT THERE IS
ALREADY A LOT OF SATURATION
BECAUSE WE'VE RECEIVED A LOT OF
RAIN ALREADY FROM PRIOR SYSTEMS.
SO, WE'RE SEEING DOWN TREES AND
IT IS CAUSING A LOT OF INCIDENTS
AROUND THE CITY AND THROUGHOUT
THE REGION.
SO WE JUST ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
TRY TO STAY HOME AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE.
>> WE'VE SEEN WARNINGS ABOUT
ROAD CLOSURES AND ALSO I KNOW
YOU'RE DEALING WITH SOME POWER
OUTAGES.
WHAT IS THE UPDATE THERE?
>> YEAH, SO AS OF 10:00 LAST
NIGHT, PG&E, HAS IDENTIFIED
AROUND 6500 HOMES IN MONTEREY
COUNTY WITHOUT POWER SO IT IS
CHALLENGING FOR THEM TO GET TO
ALL OF THE LOCATIONS, TO RESTORE
THE POWER BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
DEALING WITH THE STORM.
AND SO IT MIGHT BE SOME TIME
BEFORE PEOPLE GET THEIR POWER
BACK ONLINE AND THIS COULD BE
DUE TO THE FLOODING, THE HIGH
WINDS AND COULD BE CAUSING
MUDSLIDES AND DEBRIS FLOWS SO WE
JUST HAVE PEOPLE JUST BE A
LITTLE BIT PATIENT AS OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS RESPOND TO
THESE EMERGENCIES.
>> WHICH IS ALWAYS HARD TO DO
SPECIALLY WHEN YOU GET A
MUCH-NEEDED KIND OF BREAK IN
BETWEEN THE BANDS AND IN BETWEEN
THE STORMS WHICH COULD BE HARD
FOR PEOPLE TO DO.
SO YOU ALSO JUST WENT THROUGH
ANOTHER BIG STORM OVER NEW
YEARS.
THEY SAY THIS MAY BE THE MOST
CHALLENGING AND IMPACTFUL SERIES
OF STORMS TO TOUCH DOWN IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
THROUGH QUITE A LOT.
WHAT IS THIS QUICK SUCCESSION
MEAN FOR YOUR CITY AND YOUR
STATE?
>> IT IS GREAT BECAUSE WE NEED
THE RAIN.
BUT WHEN IT COMES DOWN SO MUCH
ALL AT ONE TIME, THE WATER HAS
NOWHERE TO GO.
THE GROUND IS ALREADY SATURATED
AND SO IT CAUSES THESE REALLY
UNSAFE ENVIRONMENTS THAT PEOPLE
THINK ARE SAFE BUT COULD CAUSE
THEM TO GET INTO HARM'S WAY AND
PUT A GREATER IMPACT ON OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS.
WE'RE SEEING LOSS OF LIFE, NOT
AT A GRAND SCALE BUT IT COULD
HAPPEN BUT WE URGE PEOPLE TO USE
CAUTIOUS, DON'T BE ON THE ROADS
IF YOU DON'T NEED TO, BECAUSE
YOU'RE ALSO GETTING IN THE WAY
OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS
RESPONDING TO THE EMERGENCIES
THAT ARE NEEDED.
>> AND IT IS FROM ONE EXTREME TO
NEXT.
YOU HAVE THE HISTORIC DROUGHT
WHICH IS SUCH A HUGE ISSUE IN
CALIFORNIA AND STEPHANIE ELAM
WAS SAYING IS THERE STILL IS A
SERIOUS ISSUE AND YOU WERE JUST
SWORN IN LAST MONTH AND ONE OF
YOUR CAMPAIGN PLATFORMS WAS THE
WATER CRISIS.
HOW DOES THIS HUGE RAIN NOW PLAY
INTO THAT?
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, WE'RE SEEING THE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND IT GOES TO
EXTREMES.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TO PREDICT.
WE'RE SEEING IN THE STATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA, IT MANIFESTS THROUGH
DROUGHTS SO IT IS GREAT WHEN WE
ARE ABLE TO GET A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WATER.
BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIND
WAYS OF CAPTURING THAT WATER AT
HIGHER WAITS SO WE COULD RECYCLE
THAT WATER AND SO I THINK THAT
IS THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
WITHIN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT, IF WE COULD GET THE SNOW
PACKS THAT ALLOWS THAT WATER
SUPPLY TO BE LONGER LASTING INTO
THE CALENDAR YEAR.
BUT THIS IS GREAT.
WE NEED THE WATER.
I JUST WANT TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
>> IN THE MEANTIME, OF COURSE.
MAYOR, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
I APPRECIATE IT.